Mẹ Amis sợ thành chiến bảo mua lời quế khóa khu bực bắt Philippines để lại như thế thạy nhiên trong
theo cơ quan khi tưởng của Philippines, baga sad báo duy trí sức gió một trăm người
gương mấy chính giời, và tới một trăm nâng mơ gương mấy chính giời,
Dí chuyển về phía tay bị tâm độ hai người đến 3,5 kg.
Hãy thống hạt tăng để đạo lúc giống chuyển gồm năng này,
cây coi bị quận ngá như tự lượng sâu thông sản rạc.
Văn phòng phòng về giận sự Philippines săng nhận có ý nhất bốn trường tình mạng
và đâm tý tục giả xuất các bảo cảo phương vòng khác.
Trong và tưởng qua Philippines đã trải qua linh tiếp bắt từ báo,
cùng tất cả một cuộc só mua tây nằm khiến tổng số người từ phòng lên tới mùi bốn,
hôm 18,5 kg đặc biển gương trực tiếp.
Giờ chuyên gia kệ máo báo bố lời của thì mạc lên khi đi vào biển đông,
làm gia tăng tích tức ứng phó thiên tài trong khu bực.